hey guys I'm Julianne Hough and here is
an exclusive look at the magic behind
the wonderful world of Disney magical
holiday celebration
the nighttime treatment of Thanksgiving
episode we're gonna do it right now rush
here Walt Disney World the holidays
don't really start until we light the
castle look at this place look at how
nice it is anything this is something
that every kid dreams of going to at
least once in their lives here at the
Magic Kingdom with our brand new Castle
show we started in January looking at
what our story might be what our music
might be what kind of costumes we want
this magical season you can bring all
those holiday dreams come true as well
tonight we're going to be performing
netted snow the boys to men version
offers the Christmas interpretations
albums he's given up with a lovely Joe
Joe I grew up listening and being so
inspired by boys to men is just
absolutely iconic to be collaborating
with them singing with them for the
first time is just a dream come true it
is so fun being able to host the show
and this is the first Thanksgiving
holiday special that we've done it's
pretty cool that I get to host with my
brother too I guess
it is about family after all whenever
you're in front of people and you're
connecting you can find that magic but
there's just something about the spirit
of Disney that
take it to a whole nother level I'm sure
the wonderful world of Disney magical
holiday celebration Thanksgiving nine
eight seven central on ABC
you